-Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know from movies
like "Scream 3,"
"Party Girl,"
and "Best in Show."
She stars in "Beau Is Afraid,"
which is in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-I can't believe it's you.
[Music plays over radio]
-Do I look different?
You recognize me?
I'm old now.
-You're the same.
-No, I'm not.
-You are.
-Well, you're the same, too.
Except for your body
and your face.
-Please welcome to the show.
Parker Posey, everyone.
♪♪
Hi!
-Hi!
-Fancy white boots?
Don't mind if I do.
-Thank you!
This is...
I'm giving you Agnes Moorehead
from "Bewitched."
-[ Chuckles ]
Oh, thank you for that.
-Yeah, you're welcome.
-Thank you very much.
It's so lovely
to have you here.
-I know. I can't believe
I've never been on your show.
-Because we've been
lucky enough to run
into each over the years.
-That's right.
-You were --
So we were
at a wedding together.
Our friend Chris Kattan.
-Chris Kattan at Yosemite.
-It was in Yosemite.
-Forest fires like big fires,
very smokey.
-Yeah, choked -- It was the
Smokiest wedding I've been at.
-Yes. Yes, [Laughing]
it was very smokey.
-It was very smokey.
But that's where I met...
-I think it was staining
people's,
you know,
clothes and stuff.
-Yes. When it was over,
we all looked like
chimney sweeps.
-[Chuckles]
That's right.
-You were the best man
at that wedding.
-That's right.
-You spoke on behalf of Chris.
-And how -- Well, did you enjoy
that experience?
-I did.
-You did a wonderful speech.
-We had a -- Thank you.
And it was in front
of a lot of comedians.
-There were a lot of comedians.
Yeah. That raises the stakes.
-Jennifer Coolidge.
-Jennifer Coolidge was there.
-Brooke Shields was there, too.
-Brook Shields was there.
It was a real A-list affair.
Yeah.
[Audience laughs]
-Have you seen her, doc?
- I have seen "Pretty Baby."
-On Hulu?
-The Brook -- It was wonderful.
-Oh, my God. It was so good.
-It was great.
-I watched it over the weekend.
-Here we go, great. Look at us.
-Yeah. Yeah, I know.
[Audience laughs]
-You've been a New Yorker
since the early '90s, correct?
-That's right. Yeah.
-How do you feel
like New York is doing?
Because you've stayed --
you've stayed the course?
-I know. You know,
I haven't lived in the city
in like six years.
I've been back and forth,
and I'm a '90s girl.
I'm really happy the '90s
are back now.
-Okay.
People seem to be,
like, having fun.
-Yeah.
-And, like, I was in Atlanta.
I was working in Atlanta.
and I had a Lyft driver
and I called her.
And she had her hair
all curled up.
She was going out that night.
Hair in curlers,
did not care
because she was going out
to have a good time later.
-Great.
-I love that.
-I think I worked with
some young people on the play
that I just did,
and they're...
-And young people
are happy to be here?
-They're happy to be here.
-That's great.
-And they like the vibe.
And I'm just -- I'm --
You know, it's the people
that make New York.
It's like walking
on the sidewalks.
It's saying hi to the dogs.
It's looking in storefronts.
It's connecting to everybody
and writing with that energy
and being spontaneous.
And that's why you live
in New York.
-There you go.
-I can complain about
how expensive wine is.
Like a glass of wine
is like $20.
-Right. By the glass.
-I think that is wrong.
-Yes.
-I mean, remember...
- There should be -- Adam's
should put a wine cap
on how much
you can charge per glass.
-It's like that much, too.
-Yeah.
-It's that's --
That's not...
-And then when you bring
your own bottle of wine
to a restaurant
and pour it under the table,
they give you a hard time.
-That's right.
They sure do.
-[Chuckles]
Hey, so this is -- this
is fantastically a weird film,
a wonderfully weird film.
Joaquin Phoenix
and the director, Ari Aster,
has made some of the...
-He's incredible.
-He really -- He made
"Hereditary," "Midsommar."
These are some of the...
-Is everyone an Ari Aster fan?
[Cheers and applause]
I mean, we don't support a lot
of auteurs in this country.
And by that I mean
directors and writers
making their own film
and having their own vision.
Quentin Tarantino,
for example.
So I think Ari is a voice
of his generation,
a real visionary.
-And I was just so excited
to be a part of this.
-It's really fun to sit down
and watch one of his movies,
and know that it's not going
to go where you think,
but you are very confident
that the person who made it
knows exactly why it's -- Yeah.
-He'll elicit
a certain feeling like,
So that scene you just saw,
Joaquin and I were laughing
our heads off.
We just thought
it was so funny.
You know, this guy
is so damaged to the like,
he might as well be in an opera.
When I saw him
for the first time,
like, I thought
he was like a worker on set.
He came in, he was dressed
in these khaki things
and his head was on him.
I could -- I didn't even
really see him.
I just felt him, you know,
And I was like,
Oh, that poor man.
And he was like, "Hi."
Like, he'd gain like 35 pounds.
And his head was all scratched.
And I'm like,
"Oh, my God, how are you?
"Oh, it's so good to see you."
You know,
and he's so wonderful
at playing
all those things at once.
And so, yeah, Ari got in touch
with my agent, said,
"Ari Aster wants
to zoom with you."
And I got on Zoom and...
-What did he did?
Did you find out? Like what?
Was there a piece of your work
that Ari had been drawn to?
-You know, what he really
liked was "Best in Show."
-Fantastic.
-Yeah.
-I mean, a great choice.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-It's also really fun
because, you know, if you --
If you see a film
like "Hereditary,"
you don't think the director
has a great sense of humor.
And so it's really nice.
-And he does.
-Yeah.
-Ari has a great --
He's really smart.
And he's a cinephile.
You know, he's a filmmaker.
Like, he's --What I love
about this movie
is that people you will learn
how to talk about movies
by watching this movie
because people don't really know
how to talk about it.
And it's kind of divided.
But I just think
it's a wonderful.
Patti LuPone is the mother
who -- owns his whole life.
But this like, he makes
this landscape, you know,
and he, Joaquin,
you can't watch him
and not just have all
these feelings.
So we all came in.
I came in at the tail end.
And so did Patty.
-You got -- What are the --
-We worked two days.
And, you know, you just hope
for that kind of magic
when you're working on a film
that just like everything
that I seem to be doing
at the time
was had created an atmosphere
around, like, I checked --
I flew to Atlanta,
and I didn't have my bag,
and like I was in the wrong,
I was in the international thing
and I was just like, "Aah!"
You know I felt like
"Beau is Afraid."
Was this your fault or did...
Parker was afraid.
-[ Chuckles ]
-No, it was not my fault.
-Okay.
-But it should stay...
-Wrong terminal wasn't your
fault, you don't think?
[Audience laughs]
- Maybe. [Chuckles]
You know, it was, like --
Because, you know,
I worked all night.
I worked two nights,
and then I had to catch
the plane after work.
-Yeah.
-That gets tricky.
-Yeah, that's hard.
-One of the things they --
-[Chuckles]
-One of the things
they put you through as well
is you had to get a full-body
cast made for your --
-That's right.
-For your two days
of work on this film.
A full-body cast,
I've had a head cast made once
and it's very claustrophobic.
How did you take to having
a full-body cast?
-Yeah, so the --
But it's that material
that when you go to a dentist
and they put that mold
in your mouth
and then, like,
[Click].
I just had that done.
They covered my entire body
in this for,
I think a few hours.
-And are you good
at like sort of...
-...disassociating?
-Yeah.
-Absolutely.
That's why I can do what I do.
-[Chuckles]
-Are you kidding?
Denial? Yeah.
-[Laughs]
-Compartmentalizing?
You bet.
Yeah. Fantastic.
-Only because,
just commitment to the role
and because you already
mentioned it.
Because I also much like Ari,
a huge fan of your
performance in "Best in Show,"
and the braces,
you actually --
Is it true that
you got the braces?
-Yes.
-Beforehand?
-Well, okay, so you know
these movies are...
Chris, allows us to do --
They're all improvised.
They're unscripted.
And we were just sitting
at lunch once
and he's like, "What if you
and..." -- What if you two?
I was with Hitchcock,
who plays my husband.
"What if you two had braces?"
I went, "Oh, we're there.
We're there."
And so Hitchcock
got a retainer
that he could just put
in his mouth and take out,
and it made him talk
with a lisp.
But I didn't want to be,
you know,
his wife talking
with the lisp either.
And I thought
it would be fun to --
to get braces.
I'd had them when I was 12.
-Yeah.
Not a lot of people
do a second round.
-No, that's right.
But people were getting braces,
as a lot of people.
-Yeah, that's true.
That was the moment.
-And I actually
kind of needed them
because this tooth
was a little...
-So they
were actually like...
Not that I would have run out
and be like,
Oh, I'm going to get braces.
-So it's actually a nice cover
that you got to do it
in a movie.
-Yeah.
-And then everybody afterward...
-It all works out.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And then you were like,
"You're great in that movie.
And also your teeth
look fantastic."
-Yes.
Thank you.
-Congrats on the film and thanks
so much for being here.
-Oh, it was great being here.
-You're such a delight.
- Guys. That's Parker Posey.
"Beau is Afraid" is in
theaters now.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."